For those of you that are like,
hey, the leads are a little bit slow,
whatever, whatever, whatever,
here's my go-to, this is what I like to do is,
during the first contract,
and I think I covered this last week,
if there's six-month contract,
I am doing a touch, a check-in with them
every single week during the first contract.
If it's six-month contract,
I am touching base with them 24 times, okay?
And of those 24 times, at least once a month,
I'm doing a Zoom call,
and we are going over the leads, okay?
We're gonna send them the leads,
I'm gonna say, hey, let's jump on a Zoom,
I'm gonna say, which one of these leads did you talk to?
Have you talked to Jack, did you talk to Mark,
did you talk to Zane?
Cool, did you schedule them for an estimate?
Awesome, did you give them a quote?
Great, did you follow up with the quote?
Beautiful, okay?
Okay, I sent you 20 leads and you gotta hold the two?
Well, Jack, how the fuck are you gonna make money?
How are you gonna make money
by talking to two people I'm sending you 20, okay?
So you have to do these soft touches.
So that's my advice, if things are a little bit slow,
things have been a little bit weird with the deal,
you're gonna have to be over,
you're gonna have to over-communicate.
I would recommend a touch every single week,
and then once a month,
I would be jumping on a Zoom call reviewing the leads.
But at the end of the day, even that,
that's just gonna buy you a little bit of time.
The short answer, the right answer,
if they don't make money, they will cancel,
and it might be tomorrow, it might be next month,
it might be next week, it might be in six months,
it might be in two years,
because they just don't keep track of their budget.
If the customer does not make money,
even if it's not your fault, they will cancel.